todd phillips joker movie has finally
cast two of the most recognizable
characters in the dc comics universe
but the choices may raise a few eyebrows
per comicbook.com child actor dante
pereira olsen is set to play a young
bruce wayne
years before he steps into the cape and
cowell to become batman
in 2015 pereira olson appeared briefly
in another comic book adaptation
marvel's jessica jones acclaimed british
actor douglas hodge will take on the
role of alfred pennyworth
a former special operations executive
operative and bruce's loyal butler and
later
legal guardian following the deaths of
thomas and martha wayne
pereira olsen's involvement with joker
reunites him with joaquin phoenix
who plays arthur fleck the failed
stand-up comedian who eventually turns
to a life of crime and becomes a joker
pereira olsen played a younger version
of phoenix's character
in the lynn ramsey's psychological
thriller you will never really hear
herrera olson will also act alongside
brett cullen who takes on the role of
thomas wayne cullen is perhaps best
known as goodwin from abc's lost and
briefly appeared in christopher nolan's
batman trilogy finale the dark knight
rises as a kidnapped congressman
traditionally batman plays a significant
role in the joker's transformation into
a deranged super
villain choosing a child actor to star
as bruce wayne opposite an adult who
plays the dude who snaps and starts
terrorizing gotham city
is a bold choice it subverts the idea
that the joker can't exist without
batman who committed himself to
vigilantism following the murders of his
parents
and that batman can't exist without the
joker no
no you you complete
me clearly if bruce in this universe
isn't even a preteen when joker is old
enough to have a failed career and a few
wrinkles on his face the joker doesn't
necessarily need a billionaire orphan in
a bat suit to make him the criminal he
is
but casting reports indicate that
cullen's role as thomas wayne will be
more than just flashback fodder
so perhaps a later act of the movie will
depict the shooting of the waynes
and plays some man who will be the joker
behind the trigger just as batman 89 did
on the other hand there's a notion that
bruce wayne and the joker are connected
not by death but by life
through none other than thomas wayne
himself casting reports and industry
gossip hints that the joker's mother
could play a big part in the film
and one fan theory speculates that
batman and the joker
will be secret half siblings sure this
theory is more than a little out there
but it does hold some weight
in the film thomas wayne is reportedly a
far less sympathetic character
than he usually is instead of a talented
physician and kind philanthropist who
does right by all he's reportedly a
quote cheesy and tanned businessman who
is more in the mold of a 1980s donald
trump who runs the mayor of gotham city
arthur might be so overtaken with
anguish and confusion following the
revelation that thomas is his father
that he grabs a gun and shoots his
biological father and his wife bruce's
mother martha
as a way to gain retribution for growing
up without a father and to make young
bruce hurt in the same way he did
or it might turn out that alfred
pennyworth and the wayne family won't
play that larger role in the upcoming
joker film
appearing in limited or even cameo
capacities rather than as crucial
characters
after all the movie is all about arthur
fleck and his eventual change into the
joker
described as quote an exploration of a
man disregarded by society
that is not only a gritty character
study but also a broader cautionary tale
find out the truth when joker hits
theaters october 4th
2019.